[Music]
in crack kidnapping news submitted by my
neighbor totoro a former car salesman
kidnapped a customer and forced him to
smoke crack all right now like the most
[ __ ] up part is not actually to force
some a smoke crack let's actually do
like roll it back a little bit and think
about a car salesman kidnapped and
customer you go in to get a car and the
dude [ __ ] kiss you you would never
think the car sells yeah and the crack
is just a bonus
i'ma tell y'all what happened okay this
is like the training day of selling cars
dude it's okay so you're like yeah this
is what I'm it's that cool it was it a
nice car at least well what would then
he was trying to buy it yeah okay so
this is what happens so the dude he gets
a severe on-site injury at work okay he
comes down on a total windfall of money
because he lost his leg and he was
permanently in oh yeah what are you do
for a living they didn't say they didn't
say but he yeah so he ends up getting he
ends up getting hundreds of thousands of
customer yes the victim they don't say
what his name couldn't that be the
kidnap he came in to look for a
wheelchair accessible car that's right
and he got a bra no actually I don't
know but so he Silverado Bing Bing yeah
he goes to a with a Chevrolet in
Tennessee and I personally I don't know
for sure but maybe the guy had said like
oh I just came down all this money or
maybe he paid for the car in full not
really sure but he needs something
because he's in a wheelchair
so he goes in takes his car to Chevrolet
he's got the car he's chillin this is a
March everything's good and then after a
while he takes it back on April 1st to
get it serviced and this guy Daniel
Bryant offers to give him a ride home
let me show you all what Daniel looks
like I'm gonna get into his car
Daniel looks like he would beat my ass
and he's a Salesman yeah he's he's damn
I'm so mean he looks like a backyard
fight champion man uncle why Kimbo Slice
his big brothers if I was if this guy
was my uber driver and I was drunk I
would mind my business you know like I
totally would I mean he looks like the
type that like would be threatening but
like might also just be like could be a
teddy bear right he's not I think so
anybody with the beard a little bit of
gray on this gangster all right so our
boy the we'll just call him victim ok
wait maybe we give Vic Vic there we go
Victor Vic so our boy Vic comes in gets
car service Daniel Bryan slay a man you
get your car fixed let me just get you a
ride home and he's like I'll do it ok so
he wheels into Daniels car so like
halfway in Bryant immediately takes him
to a bank he takes him to a bank and he
was so all right dog I'm gonna kill your
whole [ __ ] family oh my god and go
get me some money and so this dude he's
in a wheelchair he doesn't have a leg
like he's like newly disabled like when
you're newly disabled like you know
something when they have like one foot
or something they like learn how to cook
with that one foot after a while
I see that BIC is like still in his this
new body you try to figure it out and
like let me tell you my man is gonna go
off and do great things but for now my
man is scared okay so scary
yeah he's gonna get out of the car and
he goes into the bank but your man is
also stupid for [ __ ] going off at the
mouth talk about all the money he just
he like I feel like he eaters paid for
the car in full or he mentioned it you
know like or it became a rumor and he
didn't even tell the guy and and
everyone and at the car dealership knows
about it it's a small town it's a small
too small it's in Tennessee yeah
Tennessee it's Tennessee all right so he
goes in he takes him to that first bank
that's just the first one this dude
keeps him hostage from April 1st until
April 3rd he keeps taking him to
multiple banks every day mm-hmm he goes
to multiple banks but Daniel Bryan isn't
very smart because some of the banks he
had him write a cashier's check to
Daniel Bryan
[Applause]
okay so here's where the crack comes
like the headline the crack part sounded
like the worst part and I'm like wow
he's like after all of that I would like
some crack I got jacked the least you
could do is crack me out question like a
little well at least this makes life a
little bit better yeah prostitution
there right don't they crack them up and
then they go okay don't think crack them
up so I'm on the third after he had
taken him to multiple banks he had
forced the victim to take out one
hundred ninety nine thousand dollars
how come you [ __ ] tell the big things
I don't know but also like that's what I
would try to do
if some [ __ ] was like imma go
I'm gonna I'm gonna kill your family
I'll be all right take me into the bank
and then we go into the bank and then
like well I'm not to tell her I'll be
[Laughter]
wait what would say with that show
that's dude I would walk into the bank
and then I would hold him and be like
Helmut try to steal from it and you know
they'll probably won't believe you right
a cashier's check just right yeah help
me like my big thing about it is it's
like I wonder if he sent Vic in by
himself or if he came and with them and
I'm picturing that he came in with a
[ __ ] disabled dude in a wheelchair and
then this big brolic black guy standing
over him and it's just like yeah write
that check yeah while you do it were
[ __ ] home pocket - how old is this
[ __ ] they didn't say they didn't say
you know wheelchair yeah he's in a
full-time permanent yeah he doesn't have
a leg remember after his work injury he
was permanently disabled he was on
crutches for summers me - all right no
he is in a wheelchair well they're
pushing him on the wheelchair he needs
to be pushed in right and also you're
right Joe cuz he can't see his face so
from the front he goes ain't ya maybe
he's pushing them like this suspicious
moley
look at like the [ __ ] pieces all
right now guys back to the crack that's
what I just I've like literally just
wanted to say that back to the crack
with the number two so he took him to a
hotel room in Georgia afterwards after
that thereafter he had across state line
yeah basically he had drained the hole
bank account so he takes him to a hotel
room in Georgia he takes his credit card
in his phone and then he forced his hand
his phone this whole time yeah well yeah
I think so I don't know you couldn't
call the check somebody he could I think
that I think that what was happening cuz
I read the court document was that he
like he had just intimidated him ten
tamanna' sleeping he would kill his
family if he didn't just give him the
money and he was like I will drop you
off after this like just get me all my
[ __ ] and I think he really believed it
he probably when he had him in the car
he beat him up like a good thirty
Seconds first like the movie yeah yeah
[ __ ] taste would you call that Bluff
though cuz I feel I feel like most
people will not go a minute I go he's
with you he's not with your family hey I
don't know who he knows yeah you gotta
think about it like this okay so you're
trying to take money from someone that's
what you want you want to take money
right do you want to do extra work you
want to kill people
no right no that's a lot of extra work
please that spoken that from a criminal
mind teach people don't be scared
because when they say this [ __ ] unless
they have a friend with your family
right if they're with you got you know
what if you don't do this
then I'm gonna drive over to your house
I'm gonna [ __ ] kill your family you
go okay and then when you get to a
public place you go
help me please call now or what you know
and and then what are they gonna do oh
well you [ __ ] told I'm gonna kill
your family now see you later yeah
that's a lot of extra work that's a lot
of work and then they gotta find where
they live even if they have the address
they got a [ __ ] GPS it and finally
get over there
by that time like I hope you called your
family yeah you gotta go over there yeah
and he's boiling for like a whole week
trying to plan the [ __ ] way to kill
them I mean like maybe at that point
that he's just so psychologically you
know dream he can't do anything yeah I I
don't know man I might be pretty scared
oh the crack Oh so three but no so he so
he takes him to this hotel room takes
all this [ __ ] and that makes him for uh
he forces them to smoke crack and then
he drops him back off at the Chevrolet
the day that his car was done being
serviced the money he just watched too
much training day he's not training day
he makes him smoke PCP so that if now he
goes and cries wolf don't test is
exactly and it just nullifies everything
he says so he's just gonna drop him back
off where he left him we left off now if
he goes tells the cop single bite test
his blood is that she's been on crack
his whole crack yeah he's on crack I
left a paper tells me that's how [ __ ]
up mm-hm well yeah so they so eventually
Vic shows up in a Bank of America he
shows up a family member actually met
him at the Chevrolet I'm not sure how
that happened but that's what happened
and then they both first I don't know
why but he didn't go straight to the
police he went to the nearest bank of
America and then asked for police at the
Bank of America
but if I think it might have been a Bank
of America that they had seen him at
previously
but yeah so he goes back in there and
then they find the cashier's checks it
got [ __ ] Brian's name on him and then
they go find him in Texas they arrested
him for kidnapping bank robbery and it's
[ __ ] so wait he was working at Chevy
it was an employee he was a car salesman
so this guy's an idiot
because he works there he drops him off
back there he doesn't end up killing him
or anything that's how you know that
this guy's not a murderer did he kind of
plan not to work there anymore since he
was in Texas I don't know I think he
smoked a little of the crack - because
that's weird
yeah this is big heist and then he was
just gonna drive back to Texas because
he left a lot of tracks
Big Jim right there you left [ __ ]
trails leading up to his house so or
something he was heading through Texas
down what didn't go fast enough I think
he believed too much in his intimidation
skills because because you might be
scary-looking and I might be scared but
the minute you leave I'm telling
I am telling exact solutely but don't
say that because then people will know
they're gonna kill you